America's core problems in fact are
economic
can your kids earn enough to form stable
families of their own and live with
dignity everything flows from that and
that's what most Americans of all colors
worry about most so of course it's the
one thing our leaders hate to talk about
that's not accidental again it's by
design what you're watching is class war
disguised as race war keep the
population at one another's throats
angry suspicious tribal and maybe
they'll ever figure out how much we're
stealing the biggest change to American
society over the past 50 years has been
the death of the middle class this used
to be a middle class country it is not
anymore most of our population has
become poorer in real terms well a
shrinking number of people control an
ever-expanding percentage of our wealth
that means that fewer Americans overall
have a meaningful stake in the society
and more are dependent that makes the
country much more volatile than it once
was these riots really shouldn't
surprise you it's hard to know exactly
who is responsible for these sad changes
to America but it's very easy to see
who's benefiting from them they're the
same people lecturing you about white
privilege and systemic racism
this isn't accidental Citibank is happy
to put black lives matter logos on its
Instagram page precisely so you won't
ask what interest rates they're charging
black people if you really cared about
the poor
you wouldn't crush them with debt they
can't afford of course if you really
cared about black lives you probably
wouldn't put abortion clinics in black
neighborhoods but they do these people
are scam artists they're playing you
keep that in mind the next time they
tell you you must hate your neighbor
which is exactly what they're telling
you